As you all know, I am a commoner, and some of you
may be reluctant to receive my teachings.However, if you are obsessed with your
social status, you will never be able to provide good customer service,
so on the day of the founding ceremony.  "If you
can call me Sensei,
I'll do whatever you want. I
don't care if you mean it, Dido. But,
Yuu-sama, if you were from the royal family at that time, the messenger
was also a nobleman, so it
can't be helped, please."  Thank you,
Ms. Rene Claire. This is Ms. Rene. Hoss is a
heart that dedicates itself to its master without asking for anything in return, a beautiful spirit
of compassion. Look at
this and follow me.
Yes, what is the essence of Medodo? Mr. Ne. The
basics of being a maid is greetings.  Well, Mr. Ne,
everyone, please go home with me, Master. Your
voice is small. Please go home, Master. Please
go home with more heart. Master. I'm
here. Mara-chan and Onii-san's
voices are loud.  Please come home with all the necessary items.